[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend der
Friedensnobelpreis an
Menschenrechtsaktivisten in der Ukraine
Russland und Belarus kann vielleicht
auch als Ausdruck einer Hoffnung
verstanden werden der Hoffnung dass
eines Tages die Kriegsverbrechen und die
Verbrechen der Diktaturen an ihrer
eigenen Bevölkerung aufgearbeitet und
gesühnt werden denn alle drei
Nobelpreisträger die ukrainische und die
russische Organisation und der
Inhaftierte belarussische
Menschenrechtsaktivist haben es sich zur
Aufgabe gemacht solche Verbrechen zu
dokumentieren sie waren und sind
Chronisten des Grauens die Staatsterror
anprangern und Opfern und Tätern Namen
geben
Christian Kirsch und Nils Moni stellen
uns diese Preisträger vor
diese Bilder prägen dieses Jahr die
Menschen in Europa und der ganzen Welt
sie schockieren und beherrschen die
Öffentlichkeit auch der
Friedensnobelpreis steht im Schatten des
Krieges genau deshalb wird in diesem
Jahr ein eindeutiges Zeichen gesetzt
norwegische Nobelkomitee möchte drei
herausragende Verfechter der
Menschenrechte der Demokratie und des
friedlichen Zusammenlebens in den
Nachbarländern Belarus Russland und der
Ukraine Ähren
es sind Mitarbeiter des Center for civil
liberties die auch in botscher und
irrpin Zeugenaussagen sammeln und die
Verbrechen dokumentieren die hier verübt
wurden seit der russischen Besatzung der
krimen 2014 ist die Organisation aktiv
setzt sich für die Zivilbevölkerung und
politische Gefangene ein wir erreichen
die Geschäftsführerin auf ihrer Reise
nach Kiew in erster Linie geht es um die
Aufmerksamkeit für das Thema der
Kriegsverbrechen die jetzt in der
Ukraine geschehen und der russischen
Aggression gegen die wir uns hier wehren
müssen
kritische Worte wiederum zur Auswahl der
Preisträger findet mikhailo podoljak
Berater des ukrainischen Präsidenten auf
Twitter das Nobelkomitee hat eine
interessante Definition des Wortes
Frieden wenn Repräsentanten von zwei
Staaten die einen dritten angreifen
gemeinsam einen Nobelpreis erhalten
in seiner Heimat hinter Gittern befindet
sich ein weiterer Preisträger all yes
blatzki wohl aus denselben Gründen aus
denen er nun geehrt wird
1996 ist der Rechtsanwalt Mitbegründer
der Menschenrechtsorganisation wie
jasnia die sich in Belarus für
Menschenrechte einsetzt und eine
bedeutende Rolle in der
Demokratiebewegung des Landes spielt das
wird sicherlich mehr Aufmerksamkeit auf
die humanitäre Situation in unserem Land
lenken weil jetzt die aliatzki ist nun
seit mehr als einem Jahr inhaftiert und
er leidet sehr in den strafzellen des
Gefängnisses
auch hier wird heute nicht gefeiert die
Büros der Menschenrechtsorganisation
Memorial in Moskau sind geschlossen
ausgerechnet heute Abend angeordnet ein
Gericht zu dem die Beschlagnahmung an
gegründet in den 80er Jahren um die
Taten des kommunistischen Regimes der
Sowjetunion aufzuarbeiten wird die
Organisation Ende vergangenen Jahres in
Russland verboten auch memoriale hält
die Auszeichnung für den Einsatz gegen
Militarismus und für Menschenrechte
heißt es
brass für uns ist das ein Zeichen dass
unsere Arbeit ob sie nun von den
russischen Behörden anerkannt wird oder
nicht wichtig ist
sie ist wichtig für die Welt sie ist
wichtig für die Menschen in Russland
wichtig ist es dem Nobelpreis Komitee
ein deutliches Zeichen zu setzen
ausgerechnet an Putins 70 Geburtstag
gegen den Krieg gegen autoritäre Regimes
und für jene die es wagen sich gegen sie
zu stellen
und eine der Preisträgerinnen ist uns
nur noch zugeschaltet Irina scherbakova
die vor 35 Jahren Memorial mitbegründet
hat guten Abend und gratulation
guten Abend vielen Dank wenn ich jetzt
eine Nobelpreisträgerin für Literatur
oder Medizin der Physik vor mir hätte
dann wäre das so ein Moment ganz
ungetrübt der Freude wenn man einfach
sich über diesen Preis einfach nur
freuen kann aber die Situation ist ja
doch schwierig der belarussische
Menschenrechtsaktivist sitzt im
Gefängnis die Ukrainer erleiden einen
Angriffskrieg und und ihre Organisation
wurde in Russland verboten wie viel
Schmerz mischt sich an einem solchen Tag
dann auch in die Freude ja nur unsere
Organisation war irgendwie nicht
verboten sondern liquidiert deshalb
arbeiten die Menschen noch in Russland
und aber unter sehr schweren
Verhältnisse natürlich unter einem
starken Druck und heute gab es gerade an
dem Moment wo es bekannt geworden ist
dass Memorial den
auch diesen Preis bekommt
gab es in Moskau in der
Gerichtsverhandlung wo wir aus unserem
Haus unser
ist beschlagnahmt worden und deshalb ist
das natürlich eine wirklich gemischte
Gefühle
ja aber das wichtigste ist für uns an
solchen an solchen Tagen erstens an die
Menschen an so viel an tausende Menschen
sich zu erinnern und auch ein ganz
einzelne erstens sie dann in diese
Arbeit diese Arbeit all diese Jahre
gemacht haben denn Memorial war und ist
noch eine große Organisation wo viele
viele Menschen mitgemacht haben und es
ging und wenn man über die Hauptaufgabe
er spricht also und dann war das von
Anfang an
dieser menschenrechtliche Aspekt als
ging uns vor allem um würde und Rechte
eines einzelnen Menschen und die Aufgabe
die gestellt worden war die war eine
wissen Sie die war eine damals schien
mir eine fast nicht verwirklichtbar weil
wir andere Sacharow gesagt hat wir
wollen jeden Menschen also jeden Opfer
bei Namen nennen und bei diesen
millionengeschichte also kam es mir sehr
also utopisch vor und das ist ja
wirklich also wir haben jetzt Millionen
Namen gesammelt also über 4 Millionen
unsere Datenbank also enthält vier
Millionen über 4 Millionen Namen aber es
ist natürlich nur ein Drittel vielleicht
von von den Menschen die direkte Opfer
des Terrors war im Moment wieder
Kriegsverbrechen verübt also eigentlich
müssten sie ihre Arbeit ja jetzt auch
mit diesem neuen Krieg wieder wieder
fortsetzen glauben Sie das ist jemals in
Russland zu einer
Vergangenheitsbewältigung und und
Aufarbeitung kommen kann das ging uns
immer um akute
Menschenrechtsverletzungen angefangen
mit den tschetschenischen Kriegen in den
90er Jahren die auch mit ganz schlimmen
Kriegsverbrechen
ganz schlimme Kriegs
geschahen und auch heute natürlich
natürlich
ist das auch die Aufgabe von den
Menschenrechtler das also aufzudecken
und im auch in Russland selbst passieren
ganz also ganz schlimme Geschichten also
ist eine gewaltsame Diktatur also die
mehr und mehr
Opfer fordert und die Gesetzgebung ist
dementsprechend und die Menschen
bekommen drakonische Strafen für ein
Wort also für ein Bild für einen Link
sogar und vielleicht kann man an so
einem Tag und ja vielleicht kann man an
so einem Tag auch an an einer politowska
ja erinnern die die heute vor 16 Jahren
ermordet wurde die Journalistin die auch
all das aufgedeckt hat und die auch
immer vor Putin gewarnt hat so wie es
ihre Organisation so wie sie das ja auch
getan haben
wie sehr frustriert es sie das im Westen
und vor allen Dingen in Deutschland da
so wenig zugehört wurden all dieser Zeit
das ist nicht ganz so das kann man nicht
pauschalisieren weil wir haben also
viele viele Freunde und viele Kollegen
in der deutschen Zivilgesellschaft und
viele Organisationen die mit uns
gearbeitet haben und eigentlich viele
Mitstreiter auch in Deutschland die
genau so wie wir diese Warnsignal
angekommen
also gesehen haben und auch in den in
den Parteien und auch bei manchen
Politikern aber natürlich gab es
wirklich in vielen Kreisen auch in was
Industrie anbetrifft auch in der Politik
bei bestimmten Parteien ja natürlich
also dieses
wegschauen und dieses versuch also auch
Außenpolitik von der Innenpolitik
ständig zu trennen ja also weil wir
haben ja wirklich gewarnt also man hat
dann in diesem Sinne so auf uns nicht
gehört und immer geglaubt dass das den
Rahmen quasi nicht bricht also diese
ganzen diese ganze
putinische Politik aber es wurde 2014
gebrochen und seit der Zeit glaube ich
gab es glaube ich keinen Zweifel und so
sollte keine Zweifel geben und was dann
nicht dann im Februar dieses Jahres
passiert ist das hat dass das kann man
nur als seinen der einen einen
Kriegsverbrechern zu nehmen zu nennen ja
und das war ein aggressiver ein
aggressiver Angriffskrieg
an diesem sehr besonderen Tag danke ich
Ihnen sehr für das Gespräch ja also ich
bedanke mich auch
das Interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
die ukrainischen
Friedensnobelpreisträger vom Center for
civilberties arbeiten hart daran
Verbrechen auch in den von Russland noch
besetzten Gebieten zu dokumentieren etwa
über Kontakte zu Familien deren
Angehörige verschleppt wurden was die
russischen Besetzer Zivilisten antun wie
sie foltern und Morden wird aber
natürlich vor allem sichtbar und
belegbar sobald Ortschaften befreit sind
man mag sich kaum ausmalen was die Welt
noch alles erfahren wird sollte es den
Ukrainern gelingen Großstädte wie
mariopol oder Hassan zurückzuerobern
zugleich Führung Krieg und Besatzung
auch zu Verwerfungen innerhalb der
ukrainischen Gesellschaft etwa zu
Vorwürfen an jene die sich arrangierten
Katrin Eugendorf ist im Osten der
Ukraine unterwegs in der Nähe von hakif
am Bahnhof von kasacho lopern weht
wieder die ukrainische Flagge doch nicht
alle Einwohner in dem kleinen Ort an der
russischen Grenze sehen die Ukraine als
Befreier erzählen uns die Soldaten der
Nationalgarde die uns durch die Straßen
führen
es gibt die die nicht besonders freudig
sind und diejenigen die die sogenannte
russische Welt unterstützen wir Filtern
diese Menschen heraus und übergeben Sie
dem Sicherheitsdienst der Ukraine
die Soldaten nehmen uns mit in eine
Lagerhalle auf dem Boden sind Fesseln
zurückgeblieben hier unten sollen die
Russen ihre Verhöre durchgeführt und
Menschen gefoltert haben darunter auch
lokale Politiker
wie viele Menschen hier getötet wurden
weiß niemand die Ermittlungen stehen
noch am Anfang und sie sind schwierig
nur fünf Kilometer sind es bis zur
Grenze Apache nimmt uns mit am Ende des
Ortes liegt an russischer Checkpoint nun
verlassen Putin Soldaten sind geflohen
und haben alles so zurückgelassen sogar
die Munitionskisten
inzwischen trauen sich die Bürger wieder
zurück in die Stadtverwaltung manche
laden ihre Handys auf andere suchen Rat
sechs Monate herrschten die Russen hier
und sie sollen von einigen Ukrainern
unterstützt worden sein die
Ortsvorsteherin hatte sich geweigert zu
kooperieren nach sechs Monaten die sie
sich versteckt hielt ist sie nun zurück
in ihrem Büro
sehr viele Menschen sind zusammen mit
den Besatzern weg ich bin aber überzeugt
dass nicht alle die die Besatzer
unterstützt haben weggefahren sind die
Russen haben einigen von ihnen Angst
gemacht sie haben ihnen gesagt die
ukrainischen Soldaten würden sie
aufschlitzen und ihnen alles mögliche
antun
wie angespannt die Situation ist erleben
wir kurz darauf bei einer Begegnung vor
der Stadtverwaltung ein Ermittler der
Staatsanwaltschaft will Informationen
von einem älteren Ehepaar doch das
reagiert abweisend sie sagen dass ich
hier zehn Jahre wohne und soll alle
kennen ich kenne die nicht ich saß zu
Hause ich bin manchmal zum Laden rein da
bin ich gegangen das war alles
die Mehrheit der Einwohner haben öfter
Angst zu sagen dass ihre Nachbarin etwas
gemacht hat denn sie haben Angst dass
diese Menschen hierhin zurückkehren
das Misstrauen hat sich weit verbreitet
in dem kleinen Ort wie in so vielen
befreiten Gebieten werden die Menschen
auch hier erst wieder zueinander finden
müssen
und jetzt geht der Blick erstmal nach
Deutschland mit den Nachrichten
zur Entlastung der Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher wird ab Oktober die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Erdgaslieferungen und
Fernwärme gesenkt und zwar von 19 auf 7
Prozent nach dem Bundestag stimmte heute
auch der Bundesrat dafür die Regelung
soll bis Ende März 2024 gelten
und der Bundesrat hat die Möglichkeit
für einen weiterhin vereinfachten Bezug
von Kurzarbeitergeld gebilligt die
Regelung war 2020 wegen der
corona-pandemie eingeführt worden jetzt
kann die Bundesregierung Sie in der
aktuellen Energie- und Preiskrise
perverordnung bis März nächsten Jahres
verlängern
in diesem Schuljahr soll es keine
Schulschließungen mehr geben weder wegen
Corona noch wegen einer möglichen
gasknappheit das hat die
Kultusministerkonferenz nach Beratungen
in Berlin zugesichert Schulen gehören
wie auch Kitas Kliniken private
Haushalte und andere Bereiche zu den
gesetzlich geschützten Kunden die im
Falle eines gasmangels vorrangig weiter
mit Gas beliefert oder beheizt werden
das Bundeskriminalamt meldet einen
Anstieg von Ermittlungsverfahren wegen
menschenhandels- und Ausbeutung im
vergangenen Jahr seien 510 Verfahren
abgeschlossen worden fast 10% mehr als
im Vorjahr insbesondere die Ausbeutung
Minderjähriger Opfer habe stark
zugenommen und dabei sei am häufigsten
wegen des Verdachts des sexuellen
Missbrauchs von Jugendlichen ermittelt
worden
eine Expertengruppe des Europarats sieht
in Deutschland gravierende Defizite beim
Schutz von Frauen und Mädchen vor
geschlechtsspezifischer Gewalt gefordert
wird unter anderem der Ausbau von
Beratungsstellen und Frauenhäusern
positiv wertet der Bericht das
technologiegestützt der Missbrauch wie
cyber-stalking ausdrücklich als Straftat
gewertet wird
nach rund 30 Stunden Flug hat eine neue
Crew die Internationale Raumstation ISS
erreicht und wurde von der bisherigen
Mannschaft beim Umstieg aus der Kapsel
in die ISS begrüßt die neue Crew besteht
aus einer Astronautin und einem
Astronauten der Nase und einer
russischen Kosmonautin sowie einem
Japaner sie sollen fünf Monate auf der
Raumstation bleiben
der erste Tag des europäischen Gipfels
in Prag galt ja vor allem der
außenpolitischen Symbolik 44 Staaten die
sich trotz aller Divergenzen gemeinsam
aufstellen eine Botschaft an Russland
und den diktatorenableger in Belarus
heute war dann der eigentliche EU-Gipfel
bei dem es dann zurück in die
Niederungen des Miteinander Verhandelns
ging um Gaspreise um milliardenfonds und
um Erwartungen an die Wirtschaftsmacht
Deutschland in Zeiten des Krieges und
fröller und Julia rech Berichten aus
Prag
ein Denkmal in Prag erinnert an die
Opfer des Kommunismus das Land hat die
Macht Moskaus in seiner Geschichte oft
zu spüren bekommen von nahen zerbrechen
die Körper die Angst vor Russland ist
nun zurückgekehrt
wir müssen kämpfen auch wenn es sehr
teuer ist und viele Leben kostet
das Eingangstor zum EU-Gipfel ist
martialisch bewacht hier müssen die
Regierungschefs durch müssen schnelle
Antworten auf die Energie sorgen ihrer
Bürger finden die Angst vor Kälte und
Dunkelheit haben die Angst bedroht
Europas Einheit
ist besteht die Gefahr dass sich die EU
zerstreitet das darf uns nicht passieren
genau das will Putin dass wir
auseinanderfallen
27 Interessen auf einem Bild man nennt
es Familienfoto es hat Risse der 200
Euro Milliarden doppelwumms der
deutschen sorgt in der EU verärgert
gut dass sie die Positionen
eingezeichnet haben da gibt es beim
Aufstellen jedenfalls kein Durcheinander
das Milliardenpaket von Scholz macht vor
allem den finanzschwachen Ländern Angst
dass Deutschland mit seinem vielen Geld
sie im Kampf um Energie aussticht
jeder leidet unter den hohen
Energiepreisen wir brauchen eine
gemeinsame Lösung sonst werden die
finanzstarken Länder die anderen
überbieten
Scholz fühlt sich zu Unrecht auf der
Anklagebank Deutschland helfe seiner
Wirtschaft der stärksten in Europa das
Helfer allen und andere haben auch
milliardenprogramme das Deutschland
macht es richtig das ist genau das was
wir jetzt tun müssen zur Entlastung
unserer Bürger wenn man sich einmal
umschaut dann muss man einfach
feststellen dass was wir machen nicht so
irgendwie im Mittelfeld von ziemlich
vielen Entscheidungen die sehr viele
längst getroffen haben
der zweite Streitpunkt ein
energiepreisdeckel für Europa die Idee
die EU legt eine Obergrenze beim
Gaspreis fest darüber kauft sie kein Gas
ein der Bundeskanzler will aber keinen
Deckel er hat Angst dass die Gasanbieter
dann an die Asiaten verkaufen
Scholz steht auf dem Gipfel in der
Kritik macht überraschend einen
Kompromissvorschlag wirtschaftlich
schwächere will er mit Geld aus dem
eu-corona-krisenfonds unterstützen diese
600 Milliarden ergänzte zusätzlichen
nationalen Mitteln sind ein gewaltiger
europäischer Beitrag mit dem wir Putins
versuchen entgegentreten Europa durch
energieerpressung in die Knie zu zwingen
Prag der Gipfel der Vorschläge
mittendrin der Kanzler die Zeit drängt
der nächste Gipfel in 14 Tagen soll
Erfolge vermelden
und wenn Wirtschaftsthemen geht es auch
bei Heinz weiter heute wurde mit
Spannung auf den US-Arbeitsmarkt
geschaut auch mit Blick auf die weitere
Zinspolitik in den USA und die neuen
Zahlen zeigen einen robusten
Arbeitsmarkt mit mehr neuen Stellen im
September als erwartet Ziele meines
welche Schlüsse zieht man daraus nun am
Finanzmarkt
es klingt vielleicht paradox aber diese
überraschend guten Zahlen vom
amerikanischen Arbeitsmarkt haben die
Finanzmärkte ordentlich unter Druck
gesetzt praktisch Vollbeschäftigung in
den USA und steigende Löhne heißen aber
auch noch mehr Inflation als Folge
bedeuten sie neue kräftige Zinsschritte
der US-Notenbank Fett den Akteuren an
den Aktienmärkten gefällt das gar nicht
so verliert der Dow Jones seine New
Yorker Wall Street zweieinhalb Prozent
der Technologiewerte Index nasdack über
4% und der DAX hier in Frankfurt beendet
den Handel mit einem Minus von
1,6%. einer glänzt allerdings durch
kräftige Kursgewinne und das ist der
US-Dollar es scheint als würde in
Amerika wirtschaftlich eine sanfte
Landung gelingen und das erklärt auch
die drastischen Zinsschritte der
US-Notenbank sie toleriert eine
konjunkturelle Abkühlung eher als die
hohe Inflation
auch die Europäische Zentralbank
schraubt die Leitzinsen nach oben
Deutschland kann das wirtschaftlich
vermutlich verkraften doch es gibt
Länder der Eurozone denen es nicht so
geht weltweit droht eine Rezession die
normalerweise mit sinkenden Zinsen
bekämpft wird um die Wirtschaft
anzugurbeln aufgrund der hohen Inflation
stemmen sich die Notenbanken aber nun
mit aller Kraft dagegen in den USA mag
das Gelingen ob es auch in der
wirtschaftlich uneinheitlichen Eurozone
funktioniert wird sich noch zeigen denn
hier kommt die hohe Inflation vor allem
durch die teuren Energiepreise Zustande
Sina meine vielen Dank
der Schauspieler Günther Lamprecht ist
tot er starb bereits am Dienstag im
Alter von 92 Jahren bei Bonn wie seine
Agentin heute mitteilte
Lamprecht zählte zu den großen
Charakterdarstellern in Deutschland der
Durchbruch gelang ihm 1980 als Franz
Biberkopf in Rainer Werner Fassbinders
Verfilmung von Berlin Alexanderplatz in
den 90er Jahren spielte der gebürtige
Berliner den Tatort Kommissar Franz
Markowitz Lambrecht wirkte in
zahlreichen Filmen und Bühnenstücken für
seine künstlerische Leistung ist der
vielfach ausgezeichnet worden unter
anderem mit dem Bundesverdienstkreuz
die deutsche
tischtennis-nationalmannschaft der
Frauen hat das Finale bei der
Weltmeisterschaft in China knapp
verpasst das Team unterlag Japan mit
insgesamt 0 zu 3 und sicheres sich
dennoch sicherte sich dennoch die
Bronze-
und das war die erste für das deutsche
Team seit 2010 die deutschen Männer
stehen nach einem 3:22 Sieg gegen
Frankreich ebenfalls im Halbfinale
bei der Ironman WM auf Hawaii hat die
deutsche Anna Hauck Bronze gewonnen die
frühere Ironman Weltmeisterin verlor
nach rund achteinhalb Stunden Wettkampf
knapp ein packendes Duell um Platz zwei
und kam nur 45 Sekunden nach der Britin
Lucy Charles Barclay ins Ziel
überraschungssiegerin wurde die
US-Amerikanerin und Hawaii Debütantin
Chelsea
Moskau in den 50er Jahren der Bau der
Berliner Mauer 1961 Alltag in der DDR
oder die Montagsdemonstrationen 1989
all das hat Evelyn Richter fotografiert
Zeitgeschichte festgehalten im Fokus
immer die Menschen die sie durchlebten
oft fotografierte sie spontan immer
wieder auch heimlich die Kunst der
Fotoreportage schnell das richtige Bild
sehen letztes Jahr ist Evelyn Richter
gestorben 91-jährig
betrauert wurde sie vor allem in
Ostdeutschland dort war sie weithin
bekannt
in Westdeutschland kannte man sie kaum
was ich jetzt aber endlich ändern soll
der Düsseldorfer Kunstpalast widmet
ihrem Werk eine große eindrückliche
Ausstellung Dorthe Färber hat sie sich
angesehen
Menschen unterwegs in der DDR er will
ihn Richters Blick auf die
sozialistische Gesellschaft alles in
Bewegung und doch immer wartend Richter
zeigt Nahaufnahmen von Menschen auf dem
Leipziger Karl-Marx-Platz stand 1955
noch eine stalinstatue darunter die
erschöpften Teilnehmer einer Kundgebung
das muss man sich beim Gang durch die
Ausstellung auch immer wieder bewusst
machen dass das nicht die Situation ist
die wir aus dem Hier und Jetzt kennen
den Stasi ist ja bis heute ein ein
Begriff
als junge Frau reist Richter 1957
erstmals nach Moskau fotografiert mit
einer kleinformatkamera offizielles und
informelles sie wird Teil der Menge
näher am Menschen als am System
[Musik]
die Fotografin die vergangenes Jahr mit
91 Jahren starb dokumentierte das Leben
in der DDR immer situativ und immer mit
den Zwängen des Sozialismus auch am Tag
des Mauerbaus
Richter erlebt diesen Tag am 13 August
61 in Berlin zufällig sie besucht eine
Freundin und fotografiert die
Geschehnisse im öffentlichen Raum tut
das heimlich denn fotografieren ist
verboten an diesem Tag das sieht man den
Bildern auch an man sieht verrutschte
Horizonte
Richter war erfolgreich in der DDR und
galt als Sanität 1989 ging sie mit ihren
Studierenden zu den Leipziger
Demonstrationen und natürlich
fotografierte sie die Nikolaikirche die
Menschen dort
Richters Werk zeigt eine untergegangene
Welt mit Menschen die heutig wirken die
Pförtnerin vor dem Erich Honecker
Portrait die kammgarn-maschine die die
Arbeiterin fast unsichtbar macht
800 Quadratmeter voller Bilder zeigen
sie nun in Düsseldorf Richtung das erste
große Ausstellung im Westen Deutschlands
für die meisten Besucher ist das alles
neu
hervorragend also ich bin total
begeistert ich kannte sie gar nicht im
Osten aber war richtig das Werk populär
ihr Fotobuch über das entwicklungswunder
Mensch wurde mehr als 100.000 Mal
verkauft Kinderbilder die jenseits der
Mauer gar nicht gesehen wurden der
Kunstmarkt noch immer geteilt ich glaube
dass bis heute ist eine vielleicht
gläserne Mauer gibt zwischen Ost und
West und da ist glaube ich viel noch
nachzuholen auch zu entdecken
Evelyn Richters Zeitgeschichte und ihre
Zeitlosigkeit zum Beispiel noch bis zum
Januar im Kunstpalast Düsseldorf
das war von uns an diesem Freitagabend
weiter geht's gleich mit der heute-show
und um 0.20 Uhr meldet sich dann also
ein gökte mir mit unserem heutigen
Update unter anderem spricht sie über
dem Friedensnobelpreis mit Ralf Füchs
vom Zentrum für liberale moderne bis
morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend klimaforschende auch aus der
Schweiz haben jetzt herausgefunden dass
die Dürre im Sommer 2022 auf der
Nordhalbkugel im aktuellen Klima etwa
alle 20 Jahre zu erwarten ist ohne den
Mensch gemachten Klimawandel käme sie
nur alle 400 Jahre vor so eine Dürre ist
also 20 mal wahrscheinlicher geworden
und damit zurück zu unserem goldenen
Oktoberwetter das morgen wieder einen
kleinen Dämpfer bekommt das liegt an
dieser Kaltfront die uns von Nordwest
nach Südost überquert das ist wieder nur
eine vorübergehende Angelegenheit denn
schon am Sonntag übernimmt hoch wann
geht es heute Nacht beginnt es also an
der Nordseeküste zu regnen und auch aus
der Schweiz heraus kann es in der
zweiten Nachthälfte einige Regenschauer
geben südlich der Donau bildet sich
dicker Nebel sonst ist es auch mal klar
und dann sinken die Temperaturen auf
sechs bis vier Grad sonst bleibt die
Nacht bei sieben bis zwölf Grad milder
die Temperaturen morgen liegen zwischen
14 Grad im Sauerland und 19 Grad am
Oberrhein und das wird ein eher
wechselhafter Samstag mit kräftigen
Regenschauern auch mal Gewittern die
hier Nordfriesland am längsten wird es
wohl am alten Rand regnen am ehesten
trocken bleibt es hier im Südwesten und
über Norddeutschland wird ein recht
kräftiger Westwind der Sonntag bringt
uns dann nach Nebel und Hochnebel viel
Sonnenschein etwas wechselhafter startet
dann die neue Woche damit wünsche ich
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende